comment peut-on entreprendre en afrique
une question soulevée lors du premier
forum économique afrique français
cartier à versailles une manifestation
organisée par l'association envol
objectif mieux comprendre les
écosystèmes de ces deux entités
complémentaires en france on a deux
savoir-faire on à la technologie en
afrique on a la connaissance du marché
on a la connaissance des vrais besoins
et les deux réunis permettent de faire
un beau mélange pour henry pour une
réussite en arial l'afrique c'est là où
il ya le potentiel est là vers l'avenir
et donc pour les sénégalais nos enfants
qui sont ici on leur donne l'occasion de
venus participer à l'émergence par
exemple du sénégal politique
investisseurs ou encore chefs
d'entreprise ils étaient au total 350
réunis au domaine de madame elisabeth le
but
principal est d'aider les pays de
l'afrique francophone a structuré
l'investissement individuel et privés
sur les sociétés innovantes autre but
permettre aux français notamment aux
yvelinois d'entreprendre en afrique de
manière structurée par le biais divine
coopération internationale et
développement le département soutient
également des initiatives en faveur de
l'afrique
les hybrides sont un département qui
accueille une importante diaspora
africaine et qui a noué des relations
très suivies très importante avec ce
continent africain justement dans cette
volonté en s'appuyant sur les diasporas
yvelinoise de participer au
développement d'un continent qui en a
bien besoin
cette première édition va également
permettre la mise en place d'une
plateforme d'accompagnement des
entreprises
[Applaudissements]